hey Adam what about Blake leaving The
Voice man
not time it's about time you miss him
Adam Levine weighs in on Blake Shelton's
exit from The Voice and makes his first
public appearance with his wife biadi
Prinsloo since he was accused of being
unfaithful
ET chatted with Adam at the Vanity Fair
party following the 95th Academy Awards
on Sunday where the former Voice coach
joked about his pal Blake's decision to
walk away from the hit NBC show hey Adam
what about Blake leaving The Voice man
Blake who's been a coach on The Voice
since the show premiered in 2011
announced last year that season 23 will
be his last
has it hit you yet that your time on The
Voice is coming to an end I don't think
it's really going to hit me until
uh the the last episode it's probably
going to be an emotional night that last
night I mean my God it's been 23 see 12
years it's unbelievable it's to all the
life that's happened and and I met my
wife on there you know it just
everything good that could come from
something like that I maxed it out like
he said
show in 24
2021. I'm just so proud of him I mean
he's brought so much joy he's so
talented but back to Adam I want him to
know that he can still kiss my
wherever he is right now the singer and
models outing marks their first public
appearance since being rocked by Scandal
I'd say a lot of things you know and
some some things I stand by and some
things I
you know put my foot in my mouth a
little bit back in September an
Instagram model alleged she had an
affair with the Maroon 5 front man I'm
sure you know who Adam Levine is
um
but Adam and I were seeing each other
for about a year Adam addressed the
rumors admitting he crossed the line but
insists he did not have an affair in the
wake of controversy Adam and biati who
tied the knot in 2014 put up a united
front I have the most beautiful wife in
the entire world I am one of the
luckiest people who's ever lived at the
time A source told E.T Adam was trying
to make things right with his family
adding that the pair was trying to move
past the situation and move forward
together as a couple and parents we're
truly best friends we really get each
other on a on a deeper level the two our
parents to six-year-old Dusty Rose and
five-year-old Geo Grace and welcome
their third child together in January
whose name and sex have yet to be
revealed and baby number three might not
be their last we always knew we wanted a
second one but I do want also one like
five kids but don't even think about it
you want a big family who knows we're
leaving it up to you know fate and just
what happens what how what will happen
will happen and on Sunday the mom and
dad of three proved they're doing their
best to balance everything biati shared
these snaps to Instagram boasting in the
caption we did it we left the house
[Music]
foreign